les créateurs d'entreprise sont plein
d'idées ils ont ils sont très dynamiques
en général il y a vraiment un
enthousiasme dès le
départ ils sont souvent très inquiets
parce que ils se rend compte très vite
que ils sont submergés de d'obligations
administratives et il ne sa pas trop
comment aborder le problème et et
comment être conseillé le conseil c'est
voilà d'aller voir des professionnels
surtout ne pas se faire aider par un ami
qui va aider gratuitement et surtout
très maladroitement le chef d'entreprise
il faut qu'il soit en confiance
et c'est une relation très importante
avec l'expert comptable donc il faut que
voilà l'expert comptable lui il a un
diplôme 8 ans un doctorat il a il a été
formé sur toute sur tout pendant toutes
ses études il continue à être formé
pendant toute sa carrière avec la
formation continue il n il peut faire
des erreurs mais il aura déjà fait le
tour de la question avec le chef
d'entreprise il faut se faire entourer
nous avez plein de part
qui sont à nos côtés et qui sont là dès
le départ pour conseiller le chef
d'entreprise le le créateur ensuite les
experts comptables sont là nous sommes
200 sur l'île nous connaissons par cœur
toute la réglementation fiscale sociale
juridique et il faut absolument ne pas
passer à côté des aides qui nous sont
proposées ici pour finir donnez-vous des
opportunités plutôt que des regrets